depuis que j'ai l'âge de 11 ans donc
j'ai 32 ans et ben en fait je suis
diabétique de type 1 comme je disais
genre pour expliquer parce que moi je
comprends pas c'est quoi type 1
c'est insulin
2 tu peux encore faire fonctionner un
peu ton pancréas avec des comprimés du
glucophage et Machin des trucs comme ça
tu peux sortir
c'est un peu moins chiant parce qu'en
fait c'est toi qui décide tu deviens ton
propre diabétologue et tu te gères ça
ton petit appareil tu prends en
permanence pour expliquer rapidement
docteur oui alors le type 1
effectivement c'est quand le pancréas
arrêté de fonctionner le pancréas vous
savez c'est un organe il produit qui
produit l'insuline quand il arrête de
fonctionner il va falloir supplémenter
le le l'organisme en insuline et donc
comme le dit Jean-Marie il y a des
systèmes soit des pompes soit des des
piqûres qu'on trouve plusieurs fois par
jour qui permet de faire en sorte que
votre glycémie c'est-à-dire le taux de
sucre dans le sang
dans la normalité voilà de descendre pas
trop et surtout ne monte pas trop
d'accord donc ça c'est le diabète de
type 1 le diabète de type 2 c'est quand
le pancréas fonctionne moins bien donc
il manque un peu d'insuline et donc à ce
moment-là on va donner des médicaments
qui vont stimuler le pancréas pour
fabriquer de l'insuline et dans certains
cas on a des types de insulinaux
requérants c'est-à-dire que malgré les
médicaments on n'arrive pas à atteindre
des taux de glycémie correct et on doit
donner un peu d'insuline supérieur alors
il y a combien de
diabétiques en France
c'est énorme exactement alors Amina donc
vous êtes nouveau diabétique depuis
l'âge de 11 ans votre traitement
exactement c'est le même depuis depuis
que vous faites la piqûre vous-même
de pompes aussi maintenant mais la base
de ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur c'est
l'insuline on se l'injecte sur les bras
le ventre ou
les jambes les cuisses et c'est de
l'autogestion de la contrainte parce que
c'est on n'a pas le choix que de que de
se soigner en fait avec cette insuline
là vous êtes obligé de vous soigner
parce que les risques si vous ne soyez
pas si vous ne soyez pas
trop élevé et derrière et donc on finit
on finit par faire un coma et et mourir
doudou l'importance de ce médicament il
est extrêmement important il est vital
pour nous et
depuis 21 ans pas de problème tout se
passe bien
pas de problème non mais c'est
d'ailleurs tout se passe bien vous
trouvez votre traitement facilement oui
par rapport au traitement oui il y a pas
de souci en général quand il y a de
l'insuline voilà on y va régulièrement
en pharmacie on a notre ordonnance c'est
quelque chose qui fait partie de notre
quotidien parce que voilà on peut pas
vivre sans donc c'est incontestable de
ne pas avoir depuis quelques jours et là
ben depuis la pénurie ben déjà c'est
vraiment une pénurie
j'habite à dans le 91 à Corbeil-Essonnes
et oui je suis parti à la pharmacie avec
mon ordonnance
il y a toujours un équivalent il y a par
exemple la FIAS vous connaissez pas mais
certaines personnes connaissent ça va
être aussi l'insuline rapide mais elle
qui par exemple agit beaucoup plus vite
et du coup bah nous ça nous chamboule
dans notre dans notre traitement de tous
les jours vous expliquer pourquoi il y
en avait plus non pas du tout en ce
moment il y a pas d'insuline donc quand
on va à la pharmacie on a plus votre
insuline il nous renvoie vers notre
médecin pour avoir une autre ordonnance
parce que c'est des médicaments qui se
donnent sous ordonnances donc après on
va voir le médecin il nous donne des
équivalents mais des fois qui
conviennent pas et puis des fois même on
fait plusieurs pharmacies pour trouver
l'insuline qu'on a sur l'ordonnance
ce qui est très compliqué avec
l'insuline et le mettre docteur
confirmera c'est l'adaptation on met du
temps un peu à trouver la bonne insuline
pour traiter le diabète donc ça met un
deux trois mois du jour au lendemain si
vous voyez qu'il y a une pénurie
d'insuline sur laquelle vous êtes depuis
plusieurs mois plusieurs années
comme la demoiselle là on est un peu
pris on est on a des problèmes de
délivrance et de trouver le bon
médicament donc et de changer
en attendant la pénurie un nouveau
produit un nouveau médicament il est
sachant que les médecins sont pas
forcément au courant des carences et des
problèmes d'approvisionnement donc nous
on va prescrire quelque chose on va se
on peut se retrouver dans le même
situation c'est à dire que le pharmacien
l'APA parce que le médicament qu'il
avait quelques jours avant il a plu
parce que il y en a plus alors Bruno
vous êtes pharmacien qu'est-ce qui se
passe actuellement avec les médicaments
on en avait parlé lors d'une précédente
émission mais là sur l'insuline ça fait
ça fait extrêmement peur parce qu'il y a
énormément de gens qui doivent nous
regarder qui sont diabétiques Jean-Marie
voilà bien sûr
ça c'est le problème majeur depuis le
début vous l'avez vu pendant le covid on
a été on devrait tout fabriqué qu'en
France mais
en dépend d'autres pays
alors il y a l'insuline mais le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y a pas que
l'insuline vous allez retrouver il y a
toutes les paracétamol le doliprane qui
est en rupture les antibiotiques vous
réalisez qu'il n'y a plus
d'antibiotiques en pharmacie
il y a plusieurs il y a eu plusieurs
problèmes c'est un mille-feuille de
problèmes qui s'est passé c'est six
derniers mois c'est qu'il y a eu les
épidémies il y a eu le covid qui est
passé en octobre à décembre les demandes
la grippe donc il y a une forte demande
et à la base il y a une pénurie de
matières premières plus un problème de
transport plus les personnes qui se sont
basculées sur d'autres produits parce
que 1 est en rupture donc quand vous
avez ce problème là ça monte et vous
tombez sur des ruptures et les labos ne
peuvent plus produire autant que ce
qu'on leur demande sachant aussi et ça
c'est un autre problème c'est que le
prix des médicaments en France sont très
très bas et ça n'intéresse pas les
laboratoires avant des médicaments en
France quand vous voyez un Clamoxyl un
sirop Clamoxyl avec la bouteille en
verre le carton le bouchon en plastique
la matière première le principe Act tout
ce que vous avez et qu'ils achètent ça
moins de 50 centimes le médicament le
labo qu'est-ce qu'il a intérêt à vendre
en Italie en Belgique en Hollande ou le
prix est beaucoup plus cher deux fois
trois fois plus donc
30%, 40 % moins cher et c'est
l'Allemagne en 3% moins cher qu'en
Allemagne non mais la question c'est
l'Allemagne il y a quelques mois a
augmenté ses prix pour pouvoir récupérer
le marché
alors c'est pour parler mais vous savez
comment ça se passe en France le pour
parler il y a des commissions sur
commission sur commission voilà et on va
tomber en été en septembre mais les gens
sont d'accord pour payer leurs
médicaments plus chers non la France
c'est pas gratuit quand même alors on
laisse mourir les gens
le truc le problème qu'il y a le
problème c'est que tu vas augmenter tu
vas augmenter les médicaments ça va
retomber encore sur l'état la sécurité
sociale
non mais là il y a un problème de
système de concurrence avec les autres
pays donc seront avantageux Focus qui
vendront plus jamais
en fait c'est la partie émergée
d'aniceberg d'une feuille complète d'un
système de exactement c'est c'est le là
on parle du médicament mais on a la même
chose avec les médecins à l'hôpital on a
les mêmes choses avec les médecins en
ville qui sont en grève parce qu'il y a
une négociation qui se fait avec un état
qui n'entend pas et donc c'est juste le
résultat de tout ça c'est à dire que moi
j'avais espéré que pendant la période du
covid nos autorités est compris qu'il
fallait changer un système il fallait le
réformer qu'il fallait travailler
et c'est même pire aujourd'hui puisqu'on
a accumulé on parlait de la chier on
parlait des matières premières il y en a
plus parce que la Chine elle est en
pleine épidémie covid puisque vous avez
vu qu'elle avait libéré en fait les des
Chinois et donc ils ont attrapé le covid
et donc elle a besoin de des médicaments
aussi donc c'est logique elle se servent
avant de vendre à l'extérieur donc c'est
un vrai une vraie faillite du système de
santé alors juste il faut savoir aussi
je sais que vous avez de mes équipes
vous avez eu extrêmement peur vous êtes
dit un moment comment je vais faire s'il
y a plus d'insuline vous avez peut-être
devoir changer votre traitement vous
avez eu peur de vous j'ai peur de mourir
parce qu'en fait c'est c'est vital pour
moi donc avant toutes les choses de la
vie moi la base de tout si je pars en
voyage si je sors de chez moi quand je
me réveille c'est toujours l'insuline
c'est une surveillance constante c'est
de l'autogestion de tous les jours de
chaque minute de ma vie je prends plus
de 100 décisions par jour juste pour
survivre pour me dire que bah
aujourd'hui je vais pouvoir passer ma
journée normalement donc déjà ça c'est
juste être diabétique de type 1
aujourd'hui j'entends que il y a plus
d'insuline je vais moi-même à la
formation on me dit qu'il y a pas mon
traitement j'ai peur en fait j'ai peur
j'ai peur à savoir que déjà moi je suis
un cas un petit peu particulier parce
que j'ai je suis diabétique depuis
longtemps donc depuis que j'ai l'âge de
11 ans j'ai été dans une période de déni
pendant un moment donc je faisais pas
mes traitements comme il fallait donc
j'étais en manque d'insuline
indirectement vu que je m'étais pas tout
ce qu'il fallait comme il fallait et ça
m'a causé des complications parce que le
diabète c'est une maladie qui
silencieuse et qui peut causer beaucoup
de complications avant la mort donc j'ai
les yeux qui sont touchés l'estomac les
jambes et le pire entre guillemets les
reins donc là je suis en attente de
graisse donc moi déjà mon diabète est
très compliqué
j'ai tout ça sur les épaules c'est mon
combat de tous les jours tous les jours
je dois pas vivre mais survivre et quand
je vois qu'il y a un manque d'insuline
qui a une pénurie d'insuline j'ai peur
en fait j'ai peur de mourir j'ai peur
que bah que demain tout s'arrête parce
que je vais pas trouver mes traitements
en fait
0 d'insuline on meurt en trois semaines
à peu près on fait un commodes
diabétique
pour noter les spectateurs docteur
bobotte quels sont les symptômes voilà
parce que il y a des gens qui nous
regardent qui savent pas comment comment
on comment on sait qu'on est diabétique
c'est quoi les premiers symptômes le
signe le plus caractéristique c'est le
syndrome polyuropolithique c'est-à-dire
ce sont des gens qui vont se mettre à
boire énormément d'eau évidemment il y
aurait beaucoup et immigrissent et donc
dans les dans le qu'on va faire
systématiquement on va faire une
glycémie à jeun et c'est là où on va
trouver une hyperglycémie on va aller
chercher et pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui se passe donc c'est quand on boit
énormément d'eau déjà il faut syndrome
il faut boire beaucoup et il faut
maigrir d'accord donc et ça c'est assez
caractéristique et quand on a l'habitude
et qu'on voit les patients on fait des
examens sanguins mais c'est un examen
hyper simple c'est une glycémie agence
ça se fait très simplement ou un
laboratoire et ça permet de faire le
diagnostic d'accord et donc après on a
parlé aussi de troubles de la vue alors
les troupes de la vue
ça fait partie des complications du
diabète comme disait Yamina souvent les
diabétiques de type 1 sont sont
diabétiques assez jeune et il y a
toujours cette phase de déni quand ça
arrive on préadolescence ou très
compliqué comme n'importe quel
adolescent de faire suivre un traitement
parce que c'est un traitement à vie
comme vous le disiez c'est un traitement
tous les jours donc c'est compliqué
d'accepter il y a une phase de refus
pourquoi moi et puis ensuite on commence
à accepter mais la maladie a commencé à
faire son effet et elle il y a des
complications et notamment les
complications oculaires alors pour noter
les Bruno et voilà qui se disent c'est
pas possible déjà je trouvais plus du
dolibrage je trouvais pas de
d'antibiotiques là maintenant on dit que
c'est l'insuline qui fait défaut en
pharmacie est-ce que vous nous confirmez
tout ça oui alors ça c'est une c'est une
évidence au quotidien dans la pharmacie
vous vous êtes vraiment les pharmaciens
on est en galère on trouve pas on arrive
à recevoir deux ou trois boîtes de
clamoxyde de 3 boîtes d'Augmentin des le
problème c'est que c'est même les
génériquesurs n'ont pas ces produits
c'est ça alors
c'est des génériques c'est ceux qui font
voilà c'est pas du clamoxyde c'est
amoxicilline amoxicilline ça veut dire
que la matière première est en rupture
d'accord donc il est là le problème
c'est que on n'arrive pas à trouver de
l'alternative donc on peut changer quand
on appelle les médecins quand on essaie
de voir pour voir si on peut changer le
traitement si on peut prendre un
équivalent de la même famille mais c'est
hyper compliqué de trouver et d'être
face à des personnes qui qui doivent
prendre leur médicament parce que c'est
une question de vie ou de mort il faut
reconnaître qu'il manque aujourd'hui et
vous manquez je vous sors la liste
il y a quatre pages de liste écrit en
tout petit il manque de tout déjà vous
enlevez toutes les Amos de toutes les
antibiotiques ou les enlever les
paramètres vous les enlever
il y a plus rien le doliprane ils ont eu
un problème a priori de de matière
première dans surtout d'un excipient
pour les sirops pour les enfants il y a
plus de doliprane sirop vous rendez
compte non donc on ne sait pas ce qui se
passe vraiment ils ont des problèmes
d'approvisionnement problème de matières
premières peut-être et aussi faut savoir
aussi que l'État est en train de
contingenter les médicaments via notre
répartiteur le répartiteur c'est le
quand vous allez à la pharmacie vous
demandez un médicament on dit on va on
peut vouloir voir dans deux trois heures
c'est ça c'est le fournisseur des
médicaments de la pharmacie et on
s'aperçoit qu'ils ont les labos ont un
peu de stock mais c'est contingenté par
l'État et c'est donc l'état prévoit une
pénurie qui existe déjà voilà le
problème et donc ils disent ne donnez
pas tout au pharmacien vouloir laisser
on laisse un peu pour l'hôpital ce qui
est plus important et ça et les
pharmacies de vie les officines de ville
vous pouvez en avoir 3 ou 4 dans la
semaine où tous les quatre jours et
c'est impossible comment on fait pour
soigner alors docteur c'est compliqué
parce que moi sans médicament vous
envoyez chez le pharmacien et qui dit
j'ai pas voilà et ben on l'appelle on
s'appelle et puis et puis on essaye de
trouver des solutions on y trouve des
solutions mais ce qui est compliqué dans
un décompte le temps ouais mais en plus
dans un médicament la médicament a une
mm c'est une autorisation de mise sur le
marché dans certains indications par
exemple l'amoxicilline je vous dis
n'importe quoi il y a une indication sur
la pyélonéphrite infection du rat mais
si je veux la prescrire dans une autre
indication si elle a pas à la MM je fais
une prescription hors à elle-même ce que
je n'ai pas le droit de faire et donc
dans ce contexte là s'il y a un problème
et le pharmacien qui vont prendre parce
qu'ils ont délivré en dehors de la même
rappelez-vous le covid et comment on
fait alors on soigne pas le patient on
essaie de trouver des solutions et des
fois c'est assez compliqué Delphine
préventif on peut réexpliquer comment
est-ce que le diabète peut arriver
est-ce que sa force de manger vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup trop de sucre sur un
sur une longue période alors sur le type
le type 1 probablement pas on pense que
l'hypothèse elle est d'ordre génétique
auto-immune c'est à dire qu'on finit par
on produit des auto-anticorps qui
viennent grignoter le pancréas qui finit
par plus fonctionner en revanche ce que
vous dites enfin c'est plus enfin ça se
retrouve dans le diabète de type 2 c'est
à dire que les diabétiques de type 2
sont en général plus âgés ce sont Géral
des bons vissements ils ont un peu du
surpoids et donc voilà il y a une
insulino-résistante avec le pancréas
produit mais le corps réside à
l'insuline et donc il faut apporter plus
de choses il faut apporter plus d'un
signe au corps pour que l'insuline
puisse fonctionner ok d'accord alors
Nicolas voulait dire mais moi j'avais
une question quand même pour pour
comprendre aujourd'hui il faudrait que
les laboratoires viennent produire à
nouveau des médicaments en France ils
produisent aujourd'hui ce sont en France
laboratoire français des laboratoires
français ce que disent
par l'État entre autres sur la recherche
comment aujourd'hui on peut l'étape
laisser des laboratoires français
choisir mais à cause du prix à cause du
prix
en Chine ou en Inde
et parce que à 50 centimes le médicament
le Clamoxyl sirop ça coûte trop cher et
c'est là d'urgence
comment ça s'est passé pour les masques
on va pas en parler bien sûr il y a des
gens c'est exactement la même chose en
français qui pourront plus soigner le
pouvoir je suis pas un qui là-dessus on
va trouver des solutions des
alternatives on travaille avec les
médecins on travaille avec les hôpitaux
on est on est on est le corps médical on
est en contact ensemble mais il faut
trouver des alternatives mais surtout
qu'on soit aidé de l'État pour trouver
justement ces solutions et de peut-être
fabriqués en France mais après il y a
les il y a l'écologie les usines
chimiques qui peuvent s'installer en
France est-ce qu'ils vont avoir
l'autorisation de fabriquer des produits
inflammables exclusif je ne sais pas
donc si vous voulez tout ça c'est un
enchaînement de problème où on est
démuni comme on a vu avec les masses
pendant le covid ou les vaccins ce que
vous voulez parce que vous avez en fait
une des réponses enfin une des des
explications au système c'est aussi de
comprendre que le gouvernement l'état
fonctionne voilà Amina est une passion
pour nous on est cons comme ça et on
essaie de la prendre en charge pour
l'État nous ne sommes que des chiffres
c'est à dire que on n'est pas considéré
le patient est pas et pas et pas une
personne apparentière c'est un centre de
coût donc l'objectif c'est un système
comptable de la santé c'est ce qui
apparaît aboutit la faillite du système
à la disparition des médecins parce
qu'on est dans un système de
comptabilité à un moment il y a un type
qui a dit pour baisser la consommation
de soins je vais baisser le nombre de
médecins le mec il a eu un prix Nobel
avec ça
et on en est aujourd'hui avec il y a
plus de médecins en France donc ce que
vous disiez voilà c'est la décision
c'est une décision d'État mais il faut
changer de paradigme il faut changer de
logique c'est-à-dire que avant tout
derrière il y a des hommes il y a des
femmes il y a des il y a un risque
mortel pour les gens et il y a voilà il
y a une population moi j'ai l'impression
vraiment moi la Phrase qui me vient
c'est quand la République tourne le dos
à la nation la République c'est la
politique on élit la nation c'est nous
tous et en ce moment il nous tourne le
dos
alors qu'ils ont ils devraient nous
accompagner on a vu avec le logiciel on
a vu avec les médecins on a des
problèmes tous les jours au quotidien de
gérer ce type de problème mais si on
fabrique en France vous pensez bien que
vous pensez bien que le prix de la
matière première ou le prix de du
principe actif serait beaucoup plus cher
ils peuvent pas et là comment on fait
puisque l'État veut le monde le moins
cher possible on a dépensé tellement
de choses merci à Bruno merci à Michael
merci Amina merci d'avoir été avec merci